my name is Jakob NGO and I'm a professor
at University Maria I am the scientific
director of miele my collaborators and I
are trying to understand the limitations
of guarantee.i which is using machine
learning a lot of deep learning we are
very interested in the perspective of
how agents like animals and humans who
act in their environment actually have
some understanding of their environment
understand that the causal relationships
in it and how they can reason in it by
doing things that current learning based
systems are not really yet good at but
that humans are very good at the reason
I got into AI when I was in my early 20s
is because I thought that intelligence
was one of the biggest mystery that
science needed to understand and in
addition the reason I got into this
particular approach to AI base on neural
networks is because it sits at the
intersection of the question of
understanding human and animal
intelligence and understanding how to
build intelligent machines and it's it
rests on the idea that maybe the same
principles would apply to both so the
sea far AI chair program is very
important for Canada's strategic
development both economically and
socially the chairs are bringing
researchers to Canada are keeping good
researchers in Canada both professors
but also the students and postdocs that
they hire and they're also showing to
the rest of the world that we are
serious about AI that we are investing
in AI and that it's a long-term project
for the country
you